So now that we have seen an example of exception handling with ROB,
let's do an exceptions with ROB, quiz. So
let's say that we have these instructions in program order. So this is the order
in which they are supposed to execute, according to the programmer. Let's say,
that this is the current status of this instruction. The add,
is committed. Meaning, it has exited the pipeline and
its results have been committed from the ROB to the register file and so on.
The load, is executing. Meaning, it has left the reservation station, it
is now doing its thing and the result still hasn't been broadcast, on the bus,
and the load has not committed yet. This add, is done, which means that,
it got to the reservation station, it exited the reservation station,
computed it's result, deposited the result somewhere. But the result is still
not committed. Meaning, the add still hasn't left the processor. The divide,
is also executing like the load here, meaning it has read these registers, and
now, it's slowly computing its result. This add is done, meaning, it has
computed its result, but it still hasn't committed. And this add is also done.
Let's say, that this divide, when the status of these instructions is like this,
has an exception. So while it is executing, we discover, for
example that it has been trying to divide by 0.
So, this add now has an exception, the question for you is what is the new
status of these instructions after this exception has been handled. Meaning,
what is the new status at the point to which we can go to the exception handler?